what's going on everybody welcome back
to another video today we're going to
talk about how you can become a data
analyst in 2022.
[Music]
now that feels really weird to say 2022
because i feel like it's still like six
months away uh but it's already here and
so you know a lot of people are going to
be creating new year's resolutions
they're going to be creating goals for
themselves and for a lot of people who
are trying to get into data analytics
the goal for this year is to get a new
job to transition or or to you know get
that first job as a data analyst and
that's what this video is all about so
i'm going to walk you through these
steps that i would take if i was
starting over today on exactly what
things i would be focusing on and then
i'll give you some rough estimates and
time frames about how long you should be
spending on each step so that you don't
get stuck too long on one step you can
kind of push yourself to get to that
next step so they can keep progressing
throughout the year now before we jump
into it i want to give a huge shout out
to the sponsor of this video and that is
coursera coursera is having a huge sale
on their coursera plus and so you can
get 100 off up until january 13th and so
if you plan on spending a lot of time
learning those data analyst skills that
we will talk about in this video you can
just get a discount on that and so if
that is something that you want i will
have a link in the description so that
you can go and get that 100 discount
without further ado let's jump into it
and i have five points that we're going
to talk about and number one is learning
the right skills honestly there are a
lot of different things that you need to
know to become a data analyst but the
hard skills the actual skills you're
going to be using to do the data
analysis are super important you kind of
can't get a job as a data analyst
without them and so that's kind of the
first building block which is learning
the correct skills if for whatever
reason i forgot every single thing that
i knew about data analysis the number
one skill that i would start learning
again is sql sql is such a powerful
skill to have and honestly you'll see it
on just about every job description for
a data analyst if they're using some
type of relational database uh you know
they may not be using sql server or
mysql but they'd be using something else
that they use sql with and honestly it's
just a super useful skill you can query
the data that sits in a database and you
can extract it and look at it and do all
sorts of things with it and so that is
the number one thing i would look at
people before if you want to dip your
toes in the water before you actually go
and purchase a subscription or a course
to learn sql you can take my beginner to
advanced series here on youtube you can
just go to my page and find it it has
about 20 videos or so that takes you all
the way from the very basics all the way
up to a little bit more of the advanced
things and you know i just feel like
it's a pretty good place to start if
you've never seen the next thing that i
would learn is a visualization tool like
tableau or power bi and honestly that
combined with sql is kind of an
unstoppable force you can probably apply
for most jobs out there with just
knowing those two skills
if you know them well and so i highly
recommend picking up one of those if you
had to choose um you know if you're
really a microsoft guy or a girl and you
really really like that i would go with
power bi um if you want something that i
think is a little bit more universally
used i think tableau is the way to go i
think more companies use it than power
bi or i know that more companies use it
than power bi and so if you are looking
to do one of those i highly recommend
picking up two of those there's so many
other options but those are the main two
that i would choose again another self
plug i have a tutorial series for
beginners so if you want to just get a
feel for it you can go ahead and watch
that as well the third skill that i'll
be focusing on is excel and honestly
excel is just everywhere it's in every
domain and every job and almost
everybody uses it in some way in the
tech space at least
and so i wouldn't skip out on that if
you've never used excel before that's
absolutely critical that you know how to
do that it's not even listed on a lot of
job descriptions anymore because it's
just
it's just expected that you know how to
use it so i would absolutely be focusing
on that i'm going through a tutorial
series on excel right now but i haven't
completed it so you know look up on
youtube just basics of excel for data
analysts and you'll find lots of videos
on that stuff the very last skill that i
would be focusing on is python i
recommend that last because it is quite
a bit more technical it's it's
definitely program heavy and so if
you've never done that before it can be
very daunting that's why i kind of
recommended starting with sql and things
like tableau power bi excel i would
start with those ones first because
they're much easier to learn and
understand and get the basics down
python to me was super challenging at
first and just took me a long time to
get used to but it's extremely useful
for data analysts especially if you want
to visualize data or put it into data
frames or run calculations or all these
things on your data and so i do
recommend learning it although i do
recommend learning it last now where are
you going to go to learn these skills
the first place that i would start with
is youtube there are so many amazing
free courses that you can take on
youtube so you just get a basic simple
understanding of these skills before you
go and pay for something after that i
would head over to coursera and i'm not
just saying that because they're the
sponsor of this video i'm saying that
because i've been using corsair for
years two courses that i would recommend
on coursera are the ibm data analyst
professional certificate and the google
data analyst professional certificate
the ibm data analyst certificate is
going to have all the skills that i just
mentioned and then at the end you have a
certificate that you can put on your
linkedin or on your resume which we'll
get to in a little bit uh if you are a
true beginner and if you really are just
getting into this field and you don't
know any of those skills yet
that one might be a little bit too
difficult and i've taken it myself i've
also taken the data science or ibm data
science certificate as well
they can be challenging at times so if
you're a true beginner the google data
analyst professional certificate may be
the way to go because it really truly is
for beginners and again at the end of it
you get a certificate that you can use
to kind of show that you've learned
these skills
and hopefully that will help you get a
job in the future now after you learn
all of those skills you need to be able
to show hiring managers or recruiters
that you actually know those skills and
how are you going to do that you need to
create a portfolio a portfolio is where
you can create projects and actually
show off these skills and then put them
all in kind of one place on a website
and then somebody can go and look at
these and say wow this guy actually
knows how to use sql or python or
tableau and then they feel a lot more
confident hiring you this is honestly
one of the biggest things that you can
do to help yourself get noticed and get
a job and show employers that you know
these skills but it's one of the biggest
things that people don't do because it's
kind of challenging it can take a long
time to think about a good project do it
well put it somewhere and it can be
really difficult to just do in general
and so that's why i created the data
analyst portfolio project series where i
walk through five projects and you can
do all of them and walk through all of
them and create a portfolio website at
the end which i show you how to do
that's a huge plug for me but honestly
it's a huge plug for you because i'm
showing you how to do these projects and
then at the end you have an entire
portfolio project and at the end you
have my complete permission to use it as
your own portfolio because you were the
one who walked through it and put in the
work and put in the effort to actually
create it and so share that with people
and put that on your resume because that
will genuinely help you get a job the
very next thing that you need to do is
to create a resume and it's pretty
self-explanatory you kind of need a
resume to get a job these days you know
maybe in the future we won't need
resumes anymore but you know in 2022 you
definitely need a resume so you know put
all those skills that you learned put
those certificates put those portfolio
projects all those things that we just
talked about if you do them will create
a resume for you you may have absolutely
no experience uh you know before this
you may have a completely different job
or you're right out of college but if
you do all those things that we just
talked about you have all the skills and
you'll have the projects and you'll be
able to create a resume from scratch i
have several videos talking about how
you can create a data analyst resume
with all my recommendations and things
to do i will leave a link in the
description with that video now the next
thing that you should do is update your
linkedin now a lot of people not
everybody but a lot of people will check
somebody's linkedin after they get their
resume like they're really interested in
somebody they go and they start
searching for them or they check out
their linkedin i know that when i was on
the hiring team for my last team and you
know me as a manager now i do that i'm
gonna check your linkedin and so if your
linkedin basically has nothing you know
it doesn't really help me that much or
it could hurt you but if you have a
really good linkedin with all of your
projects and your skills and you know
you've created posts and you're engaged
in the community that's just a really
good sign now after you have done every
single thing on this list so far the
very last thing that i would do is start
working with a recruiter to find a job
now not everybody has a recruiter in
their area but a lot of the places that
are hiring data analysts are going to be
in main metropolitan areas that do have
recruiters and so if you're kind of out
in the middle of nowhere you can find
you know recruiters for remote jobs or
you can find recruiters in main areas
that hire for remote jobs a lot of
places in like the middle of idaho or
like utah it's not going to be a lot of
data analyst jobs if you're out in the
middle of nowhere that's just the honest
truth and so if you're looking for a
remote job you know maybe you've tried
to find a recruiter in some metropolitan
area or help you find an in-person job
that you're willing to relocate for and
one of the best places to reach out to
recruiters is on linkedin you know
recruiters are everywhere on linkedin
and if you haven't been on here for a
long time you'll probably be getting
messages from recruiters asking if you
want a job in this or that and so you
can find recruiters here on linkedin and
i have an entire video dedicated to show
you how to do that so i highly recommend
looking at that and seeing how i would
do that if i were in your shoes now at
the beginning i promised you time frames
for all of these steps and i want to do
that i didn't want to do it throughout
the video because i felt like it would
just been kind of confusing uh but i'm
going to give it to you all right now so
the very first step was learning the
right skills and to be upfront this one
is going to take the longest by far it's
just that initial investment to learn
those skills i would be investing around
two to three months at least an hour or
two a day if you can swing it to be
learning all these skills in those two
to three months you should absolutely
learn the basics of all these skills if
not learning the intermediate level
concepts of all of these skills for step
number two which is creating a portfolio
and a portfolio website i would be
spending about one month doing this now
i say one month but it could take
shorter or it could take longer it could
be a lot shorter if you use my series
and that's all you do but if you want to
do more and more difficult projects and
come up with those on your own those can
take a while and so you know i would
give yourself about a month to be able
to do all of that and get everything set
up so right now we're sitting at around
three to four month range the very next
thing is creating a resume and honestly
with the first two steps uh taking about
two to three months and then a month
this one is crazy short this one should
take you about a week if you just create
a simple resume that highlights all the
things that we just talked about you
know it can get you a long way so it
doesn't have to be crazy fancy it
doesn't have to have every single thing
that you've ever done in your life you
know you just keep it simple and use the
things i tell you in in you know that
other video that i showed you how to
create that resume and it honestly
shouldn't take that long the next step
was updating your linkedin and i would
give yourself a week for this you should
just be able to get on linkedin update
all this stuff and make it look good
honestly it should take you a day but
i'm going to give you a week as just
kind of like push yourself to get it
done within a week and not procrastinate
it longer now the very last step is
working with a recruiter and finding a
job and so i'm actually going to kind of
break that into two steps because the
first one is just working with a
recruiter and you can get in touch with
recruiter and start working with them in
about two to three weeks you know
reaching out doing cold emails cold
messages on linkedin all that good stuff
you can do that within a couple weeks so
i would give yourself three weeks to do
that defining the job piece can vary
greatly it can take somebody a month to
find a job it can take somebody six
months or even up to a year to find a
job if you know they're just not a great
area for jobs or you know they're an
absolute beginner and they don't have a
fantastic resume or portfolio it can
take some people a lot longer just for
various reasons and so that one is going
to vary extremely widely so if you were
following along with the time frame it
was two to three months to actually
learn the skills it was another month to
create the portfolio website then you
had a week for a resume a week for
linkedin so that's four and a half
months and then you have two to three
weeks to work with a recruiter and then
a lot longer to find a job so you're
looking at roughly around five months to
do all of those things now that gets you
all set up to actually find a job and
then you know it can take a while to
find a job so it can take somebody one
month or it could take somebody six
months or even longer and it just varies
on all those things that we just talked
about and so you're looking at six
months to a year to completely make that
transition from scratch i hope that in
2022 you absolutely crush it and work
super hard to become a data analyst
thank you guys so much for watching i
really appreciate it if you like this
video be sure to like and subscribe
below and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you